whether or not you have been to an
audition we all know it can be a roller
coaster ride of emotions sometimes
things can feel off but turn out to have
gone really well these big Hollywood
names are no exception to the audition
experience and these actors did not
think these roles were in their future
number one Dominic West almost uncast
himself after Dominic was chosen to play
Prince Charles in the crown following
Josh O'Connor's portrayal of the royal
naysayers had a field day this caused
Dominic to question how convincingly he
could pull off the part it's quite
disconcerting as I didn't look anything
like him when I looked in the mirror
Dominic said to the publication I kept
telling the producers that they had cast
the wrong person these producers then
explained that this was not a show of
imitations Dominic explained and he
continued with the role number two Emma
Darcy didn't even know that she was
auditioning for Game of Thrones Darcy
said initially we were given made up
guides for an unnamed project for an
unnamed Network and I'm very naive so I
was like oh I don't know what it is I
hear that other people knew I don't know
how I didn't receive that information
number three this story sounds like a
dream come true young actor Ali Carvalho
won the part of The Adventurous teenager
in Disney's Moana even though she was
not even auditioning for it at the time
crevalho had sent in a tape to a charity
singing competition in her home of
Hawaii but didn't place she must have
been pleasantly surprised when she
learned that her tape fell into the
hands of a Disney casting director which
led to her getting the title role number
four ah sibling rivalry Chris felt good
about his Thor audition but realized he
was likely deemed unsuited for the part
when he didn't hear back for months at
the same time his brother Liam sent in
an audition tape and got two callbacks
for the role which made him further
wonder why he didn't get a second
audition Chris's manager called the
casting department and they agreed to
meet with him again this time with his
mom's help Chris was offered the job
Chris said I did an audition in
Vancouver in this hotel room with my mom
reading Anthony Hopkins part she must
have nailed it because it got me back in
the room and that second audition was a
lot different than my first one I came
in kind of with a little I guess
motivation and maybe frustration that my
little brother had gotten further than
me number five would Game of Thrones
still be the same if kit Harrington
hadn't landed the role of Jon Snow the
night before his audition time
Harrington got into a fight at a
McDonald's winning himself a black eye
we can only imagine how he must have
felt about the bad timing they're
noticing every young Brits in the UK for
whatever reason the producers had three
auditions and they sort of supported me
on the second one thankfully the casting
directors felt his black eye and the
fact he was defending his girlfriend
gave him some Merit and much to his
surprise Harrington landed the role
upset enough
number six actor Tom Felton originally
auditioned for both the roles of Harry
Potter and Ron Weasley in the Harry
Potter series we can only imagine how he
must have felt being moved from role to
role like that as we know those roles
went to Daniel Radcliffe and Rupert
Grint and Tom probably wondered if he
was going to make it into the film at
all instead Tom was offered the part of
Draco Malfoy Felton has said that he's
grateful he was cast as Draco because he
doesn't think anyone else could have
done the job Radcliffe and Grint did
number seven can you imagine this mean
girls change up on Wednesdays we were
pink at first The Producers wanted Lohan
to play Regina George she was probably
frustrated to hear the role eventually
went to Rachel McAdams but her spirits
were probably lifted to hear that she
was offered the part of Katie Herron The
Story Goes that after Freaky Friday came
out Lohan's popularity skyrocketed they
were worried the audience wouldn't like
her as the villain number eight
producers of Mean Girls intended for
Rachel McAdams to play the role of Katie
Herron Katie was eventually played by
Lindsay Lohan which probably led to some
frustration on Rachel's part this
juggling of casting intentions ended
well for everyone though as Rachel was
asked to play Regina George director
Mark water said he thought McAdams was
too old for the part of Katie but found
her age helped her play the intimidating
Regina George opposite the younger
Lindsay Lohan number nine Amanda
Seyfried originally auditioned for the
role of Regina George in Mean Girls
seifried not only auditioned for the
role of Regina but she almost had it
director Mark Waters said that she was
brilliant as Regina adding she played it
in a much more ethereal but still kind
of scary way she was more frightening
but oddly less intimidating we wonder
how Amanda felt about the part being
offered to Rachel McAdams whatever she
was feeling she was probably very happy
to hear that she was offered the part of
Karen Smith number 10. Kirsten Dunst
thought she was going to play Gwen Stacy
in Spider-Man Kirsten Dunst revealed
that when she met Sam Raimi and was
flipping through through the comics she
thought she would play Gwen Stacy due to
their physical similarities Kirsten was
probably shocked to hear she was offered
the role of Mary Jane and admitted she
wasn't familiar with Mary Jane and
Peter's relationship once she got the
role Dunst said she did lots of research
number 11. bespoke roles only please and
thanks Chris Colfer originally
auditioned to play the role of Artie
Abrams in Glee but was probably
disappointed to hear he didn't get the
role and that it had been offered to
Kevin McHale it wasn't over for Chris
though Creator Ryan Murphy liked Colfer
so much that Ryan actually invented the
character of Kurt Hummel specifically
for him number 12. Anne was not the
first choice for her role in Devil Wears
Prada much to her frustration and was
actually the ninth actor chosen to play
Andrea sacks in the Devil Wears Prada
director David Frankel said that Rachel
McAdams was offered the part three times
but continuously declined David also
stated it didn't go well with the studio
when they began to approach Anne about
the park art in spite of this Anne was
determined to get the part Meryl Streep
then watched a scene of Anne's from
Brokeback Mountain and met with the
actor after this Merrell said Anne was
great and believed they would work well
together which helped seal the deal for
Anne to secure the job and called it the
easiest yes in the world when she was
finally given the opportunity to play
Andrea I patiently waited until it was
my turn and I got the call and said I
remember the moment I found out I got
the part and I just ran screaming
through my apartment I had a bunch of
friends over at the time I just jumped
up in the living room and screamed I'm
going to be in The Devil Wears Prada
number 13 Zac Efron was a convincing
link Larkin in the 2007 hairspray remake
but the director of the film Adam
shankman first said no when Zach tried
out for the role he came in to audition
sweet and Goofy like he is in High
School Musical nothing like sexy link
Larkin Zach must have thought he was
definitely not getting this role it was
Adam's sister and business partner
Jennifer gibgott who helped him
recognize Zack's star power after
speaking with Jennifer Adam decided to
cast Zach as link he said I told my
sister who said you better make him like
link then because I'm telling you right
now he is going to be the biggest star
in the world and then I got it number 14
when Kate first auditioned for Rose in
Titanic director James Cameron was
initially uncertain about hiring her for
the part James was looking for an Audrey
Hepburn type and he still wasn't sure
Kate was the actor he wanted even after
her test impressed him Kate felt very
passionate about the project and sent
James a rose with the written message
from your rose she also called the
director and said you don't understand I
am Rose I don't know why you're even
seeing anyone else ultimately Kate's
persistence paid off these actors did
not think they were going to get the
part or maybe they did sometimes you
just need to stick with it with
auditions happening every day we know we
can't have covered everything so what do
you think what did we miss what are some
of your favorite audition stories let us
know in the comments below low